[Music]
in Graham changes news Oh Instagram
submitted by Internet gangsta scariest
kind Instagram we'll be testing out
hiding the number of likes on people's
posts Oh didn't test that out that's
crazy that's pretty cool do you look at
how many likes people get like there's a
depicts I think companies do like that's
engagement you know so like if you make
your living from Instagram and companies
are looking at your profile it's gonna
be hard to why would they take away the
likes so they're saying that they want
to test out it's causing depression yeah
it is and it's it's making Instagram
they want to make Instagram feel less
like it's a competition well then they
should take off the how many followers
the next one too I don't ever pay
attention to like so I was looking
because some people keep pay for
followers or they don't have a case yeah
if someone has a large following and
then like they talk me or whatever and I
see like their photos and I look at
engagement I look at the comments to see
if they're fraud yeah well that's
because you guys are looking at it from
like like the influence our
behind-the-scenes one but I'm just
saying maybe for the like the regular
person like they're just looking at
there is no regular person anymore
everybody's like that yeah they actually
mentioned that in the well not that
specifically but they're saying that
among young people as well as young
adults like having the amount of light
and the amount of followers it's like it
ranks you in like where you stand in the
pub people are always gonna find a way
to rank themselves so even if you take
away that they'll find a different way
to rank themselves I hate what people
when companies try to control things and
be like oh we're helping no you're not
you're just making it shift somewhere
else that's true so they're this is like
an example they have this little
notification this is only for certain
people and I think it's slowly in Canada
right now and and so they're just
showing like you will be able to see who
likes your photos but if you want to
know how many likes it has you have to
manually count it cuz they're not gonna
give you a number so even on your back
end like on your analytics there's none
of those anymore except for that you
can't see it just hidden from you
just great for companies you know if you
want to do still do brand deals so it
kind of leaves that option open that's
pretty cool like if I'm looking at your
page I won't know if just like stories
actually like how you can't see and
they're saying that stories inspired
this move because you can't see how many
people are looking at it I like that cuz
it on the outside it's not a competition
anymore that's true it's just about
posting what you want to pause and then
if you still need to do the business end
of a you still have access to all the
analytics I guess I like the angle
better but I like feeling superior
though why would you take that away from
me so much that you weren't allowed to
see the likes at all so like if you're
going to a company owned post okay okay
so you can still tell the company like
here's my analytics and just like how
stories is you can see your analytics
for your stories but other people can't
I wonder what's the point of liking
posts then because I bet overall
engagement will go down because for me I
like people's post so they let them know
like hey I like what you're doing like
so they know you know but they will no
no you you just won't right right yeah
but I do it almost like to support them
you know like because I know that likes
matter to companies I guess I'm maybe
I'm so well you see the activity of
people you follow right and if it's like
so-and-so like Nicky like Bart's picture
or whatever and then you can see that
okay the people that you follow so
they're the only thing that's changed is
you number number okay you'll still see
people liking like so-and-so liked it
but if you want to know how many likes
you gotta you have to manually count it
hmm if you're if I'm looking at your
page but if it's your own page you can
go into your analytics and see the
actual number I see okay cuz Isaac feel
left that he doesn't may have this do
his friends have social media and does
he I think they do I think everyone has
a phone but I think because we're so
open with him we discussed this very
frequently yeah he doesn't really mag I
like her news even care about it he
doesn't really care and you fine I think
the only thing he really cares about her
and I was playing on his switch and like
playing online on for a fortnight to
connect with his friends he connects
that way I'm glad he's still like a real
kid baby no we - I'm good what is he ten
no he's eleven he's in fifth grade and
we're trying it's creeping up we're
trying to hold off on the phone until I
least like minimum eighth grade like I
don't want him to have a phone I notice
that I get so sad that I'm so addicted
to this thing sometimes I know sometimes
I throw it I think she sees that to was
Lee and Casey and you guys are all on
your phone and [ __ ] and he's like can
you talk to me mom but that's so true I
would've punched him in his face and go
I'm on my [ __ ] level 20 that [ __ ]
kills me like when I catch him like
staring at me and he's like trying to
talk to me and I'm like okay hold on I
just got a response to this one thing
really quick and then I see him and I'm
like I'm so sorry like I don't want our
time because there's like it's only a
sliver of man that I have with him as a
kid so when I catch myself in those
moments I'm like oh my god just [ __ ]
throw the phone at this sliver of
moments very long right now let's just
take it forever
yeah watch you're gonna blink and it
just goes when your sliver starts to go
start to progress you're gonna make a
new sliver I feel it already like the
parts that I'm like that I thought were
cute some of them already gone but yes
new cute part yeah but I'm like that
other cute part that's gone he's like
already past that level of innocent man
you got videos bro he's go back to them
maybe guys I know I'm like I like I like
this better than you [ __ ] I know
I remember when you were a blog 282 no
man but sometimes I think about that one
moment I had with Isaac where like we
were laying down I was putting him to
sleep and then I gave literally blinked
and he was like his three year old self
oh and I was like I just started falling
where did the time go
because he's getting old and that's what
I supposed to pop out a million kids and
then you're never in and you'll never
miss it now he starts to smell funny and
[ __ ] hey you smell [ __ ] weird dude I
mean that's why people get baby fever
when their kids are like older like
seven yeah they're boring and old and
then you have that big age gap because
it's like it's like oh they'll be going
now or our friend they have to and then
the youngest one is about to be three
now and so they're thinking about having
another kid again I'm like damn you guys
are crazy
what that's a normal age gap know what
three is already like you kind of missed
the baby face and then some so they just
grew out of the baby face but they also
forgot how
the nightmare was yeah this was about to
jump back right back into the nightmare
they just got out of the nightmare and
they want to jump back and do the day
listen if they want to just clean up
poop and take care of something all the
time get a dog cuz they'll always be a
baby but they won't bite you Christmas
presents later in life and tell you I
love you
yeah but they want a constant baby just
get a dog they're always babies you
gotta feed them you gotta clean up their
poop all the time
there you see it takes a lot of
Christmases of you give I know that's
the part I don't wanna I just want to be
a grandma already and they have their
own kids and they give me presents and
they take care of me and I only want
kids so I could watch them fight over
who's gonna get the [ __ ] inheritance
I'm gonna be the old guy watching two
[ __ ] kids on the round table fighting
over oh my god dude do be the do that
die see there's a video of you that pops
up well hello kids if you're watching
this video it's a Braille Academy yeah
you should spend it all like a week
before you die no [ __ ]
no one gets [ __ ] you got to work for
everything and none of you have scales
cuz I spoil you yeah I don't know these
Instagram changes I like them I think it
would help I guess at first I was like
no but then maybe maybe it would be good
it's kind of cool I think it'd just
leave it's it's very nice of them to do
it just because that means they are
understanding of how hard it is to be a
kid now yeah despite everything else
that I think when we were younger that
we had to go through it was already hard
trying to be like a cool kid in school
as it is and now that you have an actual
number that shows you how cool you are
how [ __ ] that's what our parents said
about us back to my original point
they'll still find another app that has
numbers that they can use to compare
themselves like my tick-tock video got
it's a million we're not abused I guess
the point to that is like just because
somebody else is doing it doesn't mean
it's a good thing to do so they just
don't want to be the company that's
participating in that and it accelerates
it like so for example like if like you
know in in our in a regular high school
it takes a lot of time to be like the
star quarterback
or it takes a lot of time to be like the
loser like the the fluidity of like the
social ladder it's there's more effort
and instant losers
you could be instant loser or now you
could be an instant star so you'd like
the zero to a hundred you turning into
Justin Bieber can be tomorrow and that's
a lot for a kid to take in to all of
them be a god like it's so quick to get
a god complex that's true the guy in
Jill's high school that [ __ ] a
cantaloupe in the whole school knew my
god imagine if that [ __ ] was viral there
were no a two-hour he came to my school
that rumor came all the way to my school
we didn't go to the same high school if
I had a dick I feel like that would feel
good the kid cuz the inside of the
kennel is like cut the hole open he's a
genius but I don't know why people are
making fun of them after you yeah you
warmed it up already
coconut thing remember well good that's
not so much no but that yeah but that
was like this guy who kept Nutting in
the coconut
oh you filled it up yeah Oh cocoa nut
this is an example right what I was
talking about it it says like no number
that's great that's pretty cool I like
it I don't give a [ __ ] about no
following [ __ ] I just want to make funny
[ __ ] do we have I don't know sometimes I
don't even know how I got followers it
just appeared well you and I are like
the most least active on our Instagram I
usually like it's my personal yeah I
forget I go through these phases like oh
yeah I'm a social-media influencer I got
to make some posts for myself
[ __ ] I hope my friends see this one
[Music]